Hieroglyphics
were elaborate, elegant symbols used prolifically
in Ancient Egypt.
The symbols decorated temples and tombs of
pharaohs.
However, being quite ornate, other scripts
were usually used in day-to-day life, such
as demotic, a precursor to Coptic, which was
used in Egypt until the 1000s.
These other scripts were sort of like different
hieroglyphic fonts—your classic Times New
Roman to Jokerman or Vivaldi.
Unfortunately, hieroglyphics started to disappear.
Christianity was becoming more and more popular,
and around 400 A.D. hieroglyphics were outlawed
in order to break from the tradition of Egypt’s
“pagan” past.
The last dated hieroglyph was carved in a
temple on the island of Philae in 395 A.D.
Coptic was then written and spoken—a combination
of twenty-four Greek characters and six demotic
characters—before the spread of Arabic meant
that Egypt was cut off from the last connection
to its linguistic past.
What remained were temples and monuments covered
in hieroglyphic writing and no knowledge about
how to begin translating them.
Scientists and historians who analyzed the
symbols in the next few centuries believed
that it was a form of ancient picture writing.
Thus, instead of translating the symbols phonetically—that
is, representing sounds—they translated
them literally based on the image they saw.
It wasn’t until July 19, 1799 when a breakthrough
in translation was discovered by French soldiers
building an extension on a fort in el-Rashid,
or Rosetta, under the orders of Napoleon Bonaparte.
While demolishing an ancient wall, they discovered
a large slab of granodiorite bearing an inscription
in three different scripts.
Before the French had much of a chance to
examine it, however, the stone was handed
over to the British in 1802 following the
Treaty of Capitulation.
On this stone, known as the Rosetta Stone,
the three scripts present were hieroglyphics,
demotic, and Greek.
Soon after arriving at the British Museum,
the Greek translation revealed that the inscription
is a decree by Ptolemy V, issued in 196 B.C.
in Memphis.
One of the most important lines of the decree
is this stipulation laid down by Ptolemy V:
“and the decree should be written on a stela
of hard stone, in sacred writing, document
writing, and Greek writing.”
The “sacred writing” was hieroglyphics
and “document writing” referred to demotic—this
confirmed that the inscription was the same
message three times over, providing a way
to begin translating hieroglyphics at last!
One of the big problems encountered was that
they could try to translate written text all
they wanted, but it wouldn’t give the translators
an idea of the sounds made when the text was
spoken.
In 1814, Thomas Young discovered a series
of hieroglyphs surrounded by a loop, called
a cartouche.
The cartouche signified something important,
which Young hypothesized could be the name
of something significant—kind of like capitalizing
a proper noun.
If it was a pharoah’s name, then the sound
would be relatively similar to the way the
names are commonly pronounced in numerous
other languages where we know the pronunciation.
However, Young was still working under the
delusion that hieroglyphs were picture writing,
which ultimately caused him to abandon his
work which he called “the amusement of a
few leisure hours”, even though he had managed
to successfully correlate many hieroglyphs
with their phonetic values.
A few years later, Jean-Francois Champollion
finally cracked the code in 1822.
Champollion had a long-time obsession with
hieroglyphics and Egyptian culture.
He’d even become fluent in Coptic, though
it had long since become a dead language.
Using Young’s theory and focusing on cartouches,
he found one containing four hieroglyphs,
the last two of which were known to represent
an “s” sound.
The first one was a circle with a large black
dot in the centre, which he thought might
represent the sun.
He dug into his knowledge of the Coptic language,
which he hadn’t previously considered to
be part of the equation, and knew that “ra”
meant “sun.”
Therefore, the word that fit was the pharaoh
Ramses and the connection between Coptic and
hieroglyphics was now perfectly clear.
Champollion’s research provided the momentum
to get the ball rolling on hieroglyphic translation.
He now demonstrated conclusively that hieroglyphics
weren’t just picture writing, but a phonetic
language.
Champollion went on to translate hieroglyphic
text in the temples in Egypt, making notes
about his translations along the way.
He discovered the phonetic value of most hieroglyphs.
It was a good thing he kept extensive notes,
too as he suffered a stroke three years later
and died at the age of 41.
Without those notes, much of the progress
made on the translations would have been lost.
Bonus Facts:
• The Rosetta Stone now sits in the British
Museum, where it’s been since 1801.
• The Rosetta Stone is commonly thought
to be made of black basalt due to its dark
hue.
This is incorrect—the dark colour is actually
due to a layer of carnauba wax which was put
on the stone to protect it from oil on people’s
fingers as they were examining the text.
• There is no single translation of the
decree inscribed upon the Rosetta Stone because
of minor differences in the text as well as
a still-developing understanding of the language,
but a version of the translation can be found
on the British Museum’s website linked in
the show notes.
• Roughly 45 inches high, 28.5 inches wide,
and 11 inches thick, the Rosetta Stone weighs
over 1700 pounds.
Still, the stone isn’t complete.
Many of the lines of text are broken or completely
absent.
Unfortunately, the rest of the stone has been
lost to time.
• The stone was only moved from display
at the British Museum twice.
At the end of World War I, museum workers
feared for the stone’s safety due to bombing
in London.
It was moved to a station 50 feet below the
ground in Holborn and stayed there for two
years.
In 1972, it was moved to the Lourve in Paris
to be displayed alongside Champollion’s
Lettre, describing the translation of hieroglyphs,
on its 150th anniversary of publication.